welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man 3 is currently
in production with tom holland sharing
our first
official look from the set an image of
him in the spider-man suit
playing it safe double masking it weird
because i was always told health class
that double bagging it was bad
i'm kidding your face mask should be the
thickness of a
wall of your home that you didn't leave
but besides the mask on mask there
actually is some interesting clues that
we can pull from this photo which
combined with all the other news we are
learning about this next spider-man film
might tell us a lot about the movie's
plot i'm gonna break down all the new
stuff we've learned spoiler warning in
case any of this speculation ruins your
life
okay here is this first look tom holland
in the spider-man suit
mask over the face captioned wear a mask
i'm wearing too
first off thank you tom i assume they
are adhering to a number of safety
protocols
including actors wearing masks in
between takes the spider-man suit he's
wearing
is the same suit he wore at the end of
spider-man far from home which he
assembled in the back of the stark jet
as they made their way from the
netherlands to london
and worn in the final scene swinging
around new york with mj and reacting to
mysterio's doctor footage released by j
jonah jameson
i have speculated that as an accused
criminal peter parker could get his suit
and gear confiscated but they gotta
catch him burst
actually tomorrow we're gonna be
releasing an episode of the big question
where we dig
into the actual crimes and legal costs
that peter would be facing coming out
apart from home keep an eye out for that
but yeah for at least part of this movie
peter is going to stay in that suit and
it's a good thing
because judging from this instagram
photo that suit has such great
contouring and texturing
they really don't need to enhance
anything with cgi
unlike all the cgi enhancements they
have to do to me every new rockstars
video yes tom holland is wearing a mask
here and yes one rumored title of this
third film
is spider-man homesick but i don't think
we need to read into any connection here
the fact that he's wearing a mask in
this photo probably isn't a clue to that
because it's also
still very possible that the title of
the film could be something like
spider-man home
worlds based on the confirmation that
benedict cumberbatch steven strange
is joining peter parker in this story
based on that fact i still think the
likeliest direction for the plot is to
tap into steven strange's role as the
sorcerer supreme
capable of navigating the multiverse
something both of these avengers might
need to do if our theories about
wandavision end up being right
and scarlet witch does indeed shatter
the mcu into an array of alternate
realities
ned actor jacob battalon hinted that
some mind-blowing twist is coming in an
instagram story reaction to his reading
the script
no and this is crazy that you can
actually see this
but if you zoom way into babylon's eyes
to the reflection of the glowing screen
showing the script pages
you can barely make out a glowing void
of calmness and peace
in which we can take comfort knowing
that whatever the future holds the plot
of this film will have minimal impact on
our inner happiness
yeah i'm kidding you can't see anything
reflected in size but there is a clue
that you might have missed
in the image that tom holland shared to
the far right is
the right hand of someone based on the
clothing there i have some thoughts on
who this could be
one of the avengers oh but before i
continue i need a snack on some yummy
healthy cereal
magic spoon thanks to magic spoon for
sponsoring this video see between being
inactive while stuck at home
and anxiety-induced bingeing my eating
habits have not been great lately but
i've been wanting to cut down on the
sugar and unhealthy food but you know
papa still needs his comfort food and
that is cereal lucky for me
there is magic spoon cereal it's just
like the tasty cereal of our carefree
childhoods but without the coma inducing
sugar load
each serving of magic spoon is only 110
calories it has zero sugar
11 grams of protein and only three net
grams of carbs
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb
and gmo free their great flavors include
the original for the fruity the frosted
the blueberry the cocoa
oh actually i just got two of the new
flavors the salted caramel and
oh my new favorite apple cinnamon
over the river through the woods it's
like digging into some turkey day apple
pie
boy oh boy i'm gonna be back to eating
cereal for every meal of the day click
the link below to get some magic spoon
cereal today and you can build your very
own variety box and use my code
new rockstars for free shipping you can
choose from the best-selling cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry flavors
plus
brand new flavors that just dropped
including peanut butter including
cinnamon so many of you have asked and
now
this is the first time magic spoon has
ever released a new option
to build your very own custom box with
new flavors to choose from so don't wait
and magic spoon is so confident with
their product it is packed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they will refund your
money no questions asked so click the
link below and use the code new
rockstars for free shipping or go to
magicspoon.com
new rockstars okay back to this first
look image of spider-man 3 that tom
holland shared
there is someone on the far right of the
frame there their arm sleeve appears to
hang low
over their hand making me think this is
a costume because just from my
experience on film sets set crew workers
tend to have their sleeves up their
hands free to handle equipment not get
snagged on anything you'll also notice
there is a circular piece of equipment
i am thinking this is a large industrial
floor fan that they often use on sets to
blast wind
so my first thought was that this could
be the hand of dr steven strange it
would make sense with
why peter's still in his far from home
suit and gave us a clue to a possible
opening scene of the film like after
seeing his identity shared all over the
news peter could freak out
and swing on over to the sanctum
sanctorum geographically plotting
peter's location in manhattan he was
watching those screens at penn station
which is closer to times square than
1778 bleeker street which is further
south closer to washington square park
that would make for a dramatic dash
south by peter to the sanctum
where he could crash in through that
window to find strange and wonk sharing
a pint of a hunka hulka burning fudge
fans closely watching the studio set
have noticed that benedict cumberbatch
arrived in atlanta shortly after tom
holland and spent at least a week there
if it is strange or wrong standing with
peter parker here
the blue screen background and wind
machine could suggest they are standing
at the precipice of a portal
looking into a vast interdimensional
space a web of life and destiny
or you know they use these blue screens
and fans for all kinds of sets and
backgrounds so again
back into ned's eyeball void relax
eric we don't need the answers that is
the answer
but i should also point out that dr
strange's robes actually end with his
sleeves wrapped up to fit his wrist
snugly
not draped down over his knuckles but
one piece of avengers wardrobe that does
look a bit more like that
is the jacket worn by tony stark and
other avengers
tony's sleeves definitely hung that low
during the new york battle in infinity
war and if this movie does expand into
the multiverse a little cameo from
robert downey jr tony stark from another
dimension
maybe that dimension sorcerer supreme
even would answer
many fans prayers little cameo or
the hand could belong to wanda maximoff
whose arm sleeve does end in a glove
that covers
her fingers and i do believe that rwanda
is going to be a central figure
of this multi-title multiverse crisis in
the first half of phase four
but look folks even with tom holland's
known affinity for over
sharing set leaks and spoilers i don't
think he would be allowed to post a
photo
that contained any part of an avenger
actor that we'd recognize
because the studio knows that the nerds
possess like digital profiles of every
major mcu character and we can run it
against everything but it is
nonetheless very exciting to get these
first images of spider-man 3. the studio
has hinted that we will get some kind of
trailer before the end of this year so
what do you make of tom holland's set
photo
this mystery hand jacob babylon's
reaction video
and the speculation over the film's
title hit us up on our official discord
server which you can join by becoming a
patron
at patreon.comrockstars but the better
way to support this channel and
get some amazing apparel and accessories
for yourself or as a gift is to check
out our
new merch store at newrockstarsmerch.com
folks we got shirts hoodies
masks you can wear over your spiderman
mask hi i'm eric voss shirt
lots more new rockstarsmerch.com also
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell
follow me at ea boss follow me rockstars
thank you for watching and if you need
to find me i will be doing some
deep breathing and unwinding in the ned
eyeball void
i think i'll go into the light
oh hey janet
[Music]
you